[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, everyone.
We're grateful you're
able to attend.
Talks at Google, in
partnership with gPause,
are very pleased to have Agapi
Stassinopoulos here today.
Agapi is a best selling
author and speaker
who inspires audiences
around the world.
Born and raised
in Athens, Greece,
Agapi was trained in London at
the Royal Academy of Dramatic
Art, and then moved on to
receive her master's degree
in psychology from the
University of Santa Monica.
She's splits her time between
New York and Los Angeles,
conducting workshops
for Thrive Global,
a company founded by her
sister Arianna Huffington
to help change the way
that we work and live.
Her latest book, which
she'll discuss today,
is "Wake Up to the Joy
of You--" pictured here--
"52 Meditations and Practices
for a Calmer, Happier Life."
With warmth and wisdom from a
lifetime of spiritual seeking,
Agapi guides you
through 52 weeks
of letting go of what
doesn't work for you
and finding what does.
So please be sure to pick up a
copy of the book from the back.
Also if you want
to learn more, you
can go to
wakeuptothejoyofyou.com.
Or you can find Agapi on
Instagram at AgapiSees,
S-E-E-S, and at
Facebook with her name.
So without further ado,
please give a warm welcome
to Agapi Stassinopoulos.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Well hi there everybody.
How is everybody doing today?
Pretty good?
I just love this idea
of eating and talking.
It's a very Greek tradition.
We're always eating.
I don't know if any of
you have been to Greece.
And feel free to move
closer if you would like.
I like to be able
to see you all.
And I'm so thrilled to be
here in New York City speaking
to you about one of
my favorite subjects
in the world, which is joy,
happiness, and calmness.
So wanted to ask if anybody
here would like to experience
more joy in their lives?
How about calmness?
How about happiness?
All right, so what about
a little more fulfillment,
creativity?
How about a feeling of
feeling that everything is OK?
Yes, me too.
So one of the best things
to start with all this
and to get more into our own
zone of calm and happiness
I have found is dancing.
So I would like to all
stand up for a minute--
you can put your
food on the side--
and join me in just
moving our bodies
to one of my favorite
songs by Pharrell called,
everybody, "Happy."
OK Greg, hit it.
[MUSIC - PHARRELL, "HAPPY"]
And basically you can actually
pick up someone and dance
with them if you like.
You can move your shoulders.
You can move your hips.
Nicole, where are you?
Nicole said to me, you
can always dance alone.
You can clap.
And then you can
turn to somebody,
and you can actually do that.
My goodness, Googlers are shy.
Nobody is dancing with anybody.
All right.
This is the country
western way of moving.
And you can move hands.
And I'm happy.
Come along if you feel
like a room without a view.
Nicole is doing great.
OK, thank you.
Thank you.
Have you found
that when you move,
you actually start
to feel better?
And have you found that when
you actually breathe deeply,
you start to feel better?
If you agree, you can
actually raise your hand.
Because part of the amazing
things as human beings
is I have discovered that
what gets us really stuck
is we stay stuck in our heads.
And in this book, one of
the chapters, chapter three,
is called "Making Your
Health a Priority."
And I have about three pages
about facts about the body.
And one of the things
that we talk a lot about
is that we have about
70,000 thoughts a day.
And about 70% of the
thoughts are negative.
So what causes us
to feel stressed
is not so much what we do,
but pretty much how we think
about what we do and what we
think of ourselves while we're
doing it.
So in my journey, or when
I started from Greece
and I went to London
and I started acting,
and went to Los Angeles to do
a movie that didn't work out,
I started to discover
that my path was
very much about
connecting more deeply
and getting to
know about myself.
So everything that
happened in my life,
and everything especially
that didn't happen,
led me to find a more
deep connection to Agapi,
and to find out who I
was and what was about.
So when I wrote this book
about two months ago,
it was like a whole
collection of all the things
I learned in my life,
and especially the things
that we call hard in our lives.
Has anybody here ever
gotten everything they want?
See, not me either.
Has anybody here
ever gotten things
that they really went after
but they didn't happen?
Could be relationships.
Could be work.
Could be that we
want more money.
Could be that we want
greater position.
greater things in our lives
in terms of creativity, but
they don't actually happen.
And what we mostly
do when that happens
is we start to make
judgments about ourselves.
And we start to feel that there
is something wrong with us.
And we as human beings
have this tendency
that I found as I was
traveling around the country,
and I spoke to thousands of
people for my previous book
"Unbinding the Heart," that
there was a universal theme
of human nature.
And that theme was that there
was a fundamental feeling
of lack, a fundamental feeling
that we were lacking something,
that we didn't have
it all together,
when no one out there
has it altogether,
and that we were judging
our journey as we
were taking our journey.
We were judging the things
that didn't happen to us.
People were actually
feeling a sense
that they wanted to be
more fulfilled, that they
wanted a more calm, they
wanted a greater happiness.
And part of it was that
people were not really giving
themselves the opportunity to
discover more about the times
in your life where
you stop and you pause
and you get to really find
out a little more about what
you are about.
So a lot of the things
that happened in my life
were very disappointing, like
my career never happened.
Has anybody ever had
disappointment in their lives?
And that disappointment were
things that I felt, well,
would I ever find
my own expression?
Would I ever find what
I was meant to do?
And the disappointment was worse
because I made myself wrong.
And I judged myself for the
things that were not happening.
So the feeling of lacking,
of not feeling enough-- and I
wrote in this book a whole
chapter that's called "Enough
of Not Feeling Enough."
And basically we
feel we're not enough
when we don't get the
things we want in our lives.
So I wanted to dispel
that myth, and really
start to look at
ourselves from a place of,
we are like a masterpiece
at the same time
as a work in progress, and
that life sort of goes on
from day to day.
But we stop connecting with
the things that bring us joy.
So in my whole
path and evolution
of how I discovered things
was that, fundamentally, I
had to stop judging
myself for all the things
I wasn't getting,
and realize what
was the thing that I needed
to take care of myself.
And taking care of
myself meant returning
to the source of
my own connection
with something that
was bigger than myself.
Dispelling the myth that there
is something wrong with us
is something that we
must all do because we
have 37.2 trillion cells in
our body, making life for us
right now.
Can everybody just say
that, 37.2 trillion cells?
37.2 trillion cells,
can you say that?
AUDIENCE: 37.2 trillion cells.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Can
you say it a little louder?
AUDIENCE: 37.2 trillion cells.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
And can you possibly
imagine that these
cells are making life
right now, making us?
Cells are dying.
Cells or being reborn
cells are creating
and life is happening
despite of ourselves.
Isn't that an amazing
phenomenon to realize
that there is a life force,
and the life force is really
breathing us?
And our very breath is
the portal to a bigger
thing than who we think we are.
Our very breath is
the breath of life.
So I discovered
little by little--
Nicole was here hosting me
today, was welcoming me,
said to me, "How long
have you been meditating?"
How many people here meditate?
That's so great.
And how many people would
like to learn how to meditate?
So, again, dispelling the myth
of meditation, that meditation
is hard, I realized that
I started meditating
when I was 12 years old.
My mother taught me
and my sister Arianna
how to meditate and to do yoga.
But of course, you know,
when you're 12 years old,
you don't really
want to meditate.
You just want to have
fun with the boys.
And really you want
to have fun in life.
So I stopped meditating.
And then I discovered that
what I really wanted to do
is just dance and sing and act.
But later in my life when I
was getting very stressed,
when I was in Los Angeles
trying for my acting career,
I rediscovered meditation.
And what it started to do for
me is take me deeper to myself.
So meditation was a
practice that took me out
of my own negative
thinking of myself,
and started to connect me
with a part of myself that
is real and alive and
it is the spirit in me.
And that spirit was kind of
waiting for me to connect
with myself in a deeper way.
With everything else
in life, it's practice.
It's microscopic
steps every day.
And doing something every
day started to change me.
I started to realize that
the most important thing was
to make something
like my practices,
but to also bring
my joy in them.
That if I was doing it
without my own heart--
and you know, there's so much
talk now about mindfulness.
But I realized that what I
had to do more than anything
is open up my heart
to my own self.
And to do that, which I called
the art of loving yourself,
had to do with a deeper
acceptance of myself,
deeper acceptance of all the
things I thought I couldn't do,
that I was not good enough,
that I was inadequate.
And then as I started to open
up to a compassion and a love
for myself, a
forgiveness of myself,
an appreciation of who I was,
everything started to flourish.
It was absolutely
amazing, that really we
hold the treasure of who
we are in our very hands.
But we have to back
away and disconnect
from the world to connect back
to who we think we have inside.
And the way we start to do
that is by a certain reverence
and gratitude.
Have you ever realized that
if we lived in gratitude,
our whole life would
be transformed?
I want to ask you if you
have ever felt something
where you were doing something
and you are taking yourself
for granted?
How many people here take
themselves for granted,
or life, or
everything around us?
Have you ever had an
experience where you were like
shook and you said, oh my
God, if this goes well,
I will never again take
anything for granted?
And then you go back and you
take something for granted.
And it could be like we
are stuck on the subway
and you don't know
what's going to happen.
And you're stuck on the subway.
It's happened to me where I
would be stuck for an hour.
And you can hardly breathe.
And you say, whenever
the subway now
gets back to its
destination, I will never
complain about anything.
Did that ever happen to you?
And then what happens to us?
We go back and we
complain about everything.
Well, in this book, I wrote
a chapter called "Gratitude,
Reverence, and Oh My God."
And it was really about
being taught from life itself
about gratitude,
because life has
a way of really
humbling us and making
us understand that there
is something bigger
than ourselves.
So one day I was going
to Montana to speak,
and there was a
snowstorm in New York.
And while I was going to
the airport, I arrived there
and I realized that
my plane was canceled.
So I had to go back to New
York and leave the next morning
at 5:00 AM, and then
arrived in Montana.
It was a very hard trip.
I was speaking to a lot
of hospital practitioners
and patients.
And it was just intense.
And on my way back, I
stopped in Salt Lake City.
And we arrived there
only to find out
that the plane was
canceled, and that we
had to get back to sleep
in Salt Lake City, and then
the next day to leave
again at 5:00 AM.
Well I arrived there, and
I was absolutely bitching.
And I said, "I can't believe
this is happening to me.
This is so hard.
This has been a horrible trip."
And I was complaining.
And suddenly-- has
anybody ever done that,
when you just kind of--
you feel like life is
tragic at that moment.
And it's catastrophic
thinking, right?
It's like things
couldn't be worse.
And there's zero
gratitude in you.
And I heard this voice
inside that said,
start thanking everything.
And I looked around and
there was no one around
except me really telling myself,
start thanking everything.
And so I started to thank first
of all that the plane landed.
And then I started to thank
that I had a chair to sit on
and I had a credit card
and I could go to a hotel
and that I had a phone, a
cell phone, that was working.
And then I started
to thank the fact
that I had a family that
I love that I could call.
And one thing after another--
within three minutes,
a friend of mine called me
and said, "Where are you?"
And I said, "I'm
in Salt Lake City.
My flight has been canceled."
And she said, "Oh
that's so funny,
because I'm coming to Salt
Lake City tonight at midnight.
And I have a suite at the hotel.
I'm speaking there.
Why don't you go stay there?
You can stay in the
big room in the bed.
I'll sleep on the couch.
And tomorrow I'll take
you to the airport."
It was amazing.
And that's exactly what I did.
I went to the hotel.
I stayed in the
big king sized bed.
I ordered room service.
I watched TV.
I had a fantastic night.
At 5:00 AM, my
friend woke me up.
She drove me to the airport.
And I got on that flight.
And I was so grateful.
I was grateful for the
cold coffee that was lousy.
I was grateful for
the stewardesses
who were not particularly nice.
I was grateful for everything.
And this gratitude changed--
that moment I remember
changed my life.
And I have that
story in the book.
And from then on I said,
what would life be like
if I lived life as
a thank you, if I
lived every day as a thank you?
And I want to challenge you.
I want to sort of
call you to action
and say, would you take a day--
would you take a day and
think of nothing else
but just thank you,
thank you for everything?
So I'm just going to
go around the room
and just say one thing
you are thankful for.
AUDIENCE: The fantastic
brownie I just ate.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Fantastic brownie.
I want one of those brownies.
I'm going to have
one afterwards.
AUDIENCE: The work
environment here.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: The
work environment here, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thursday.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Thursday-- Thursday, I love it.
AUDIENCE: Being healthy.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Being healthy.
Boy, the best, the best.
AUDIENCE: Family.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Family, yes.
AUDIENCE: Living in New York.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Living
in New York, yes, me too.
AUDIENCE: Yoga.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Yoga, yes.
AUDIENCE: Well you just
said living in New York,
so I'll say living in America.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Living in America.
Yes, yes, me too.
AUDIENCE: Having the
greatest daughter ever.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
The greatest what?
AUDIENCE: Daughter.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
The greatest daughter.
How old is your daughter?
AUDIENCE: Two.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Two, amazing.
God bless her.
AUDIENCE: Indoor plumbing.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Indoor plumbing.
Oh, I had this
experience yesterday.
And I said, "Our
shower wasn't working."
And that made it work.
And we had hot water.
And I said, I'm thankful for
hot water and shower pressure.
That was the other thing.
AUDIENCE: Friends.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Friends-- friends.
And you?
Somebody, there,
you, behind, you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was the one
that said indoor plumbing.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Oh,
you said indoor plumbing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think maybe
the ability to run.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Ability to run, yes.
AUDIENCE: Internet.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Internet.
AUDIENCE: The opportunity
to come to talks like this.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
That's beautiful.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Ibuprofen.
Then we have the lady behind.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
What did you say?
I didn't hear.
AUDIENCE: Light.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Light, yes.
AUDIENCE: Actually
the same as him.
I'm just really happy that
we these opportunities here
at Google [INAUDIBLE].
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Beautiful.
Yes, anybody?
AUDIENCE: Public transportation.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Health.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Health.
AUDIENCE: Family.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Family.
What?
AUDIENCE: Movement.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Movement, yes.
Chris?
AUDIENCE: The opportunity to
come to these [INAUDIBLE].
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: For my
[INAUDIBLE] or my kids.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS: Your kids.
Bridget?
AUDIENCE: My sister.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Your sister.
AUDIENCE: Food to eat.
AGAPI STASSINOPOULOS:
Food to eat.
Thank you.
Yes, me too.
I'm grateful for my
sister too as well.
So I started to think about how
our brain can actually change
and we can train our brain,
because so much of our stress
comes from the mind and the
brain and the emotional state.
And I started to think how
if I changed my thoughts
and if I changed
it into gratitude--
and every night I want to
really encourage you, for those
of you who write in a journal--
I saw Chris has a beautiful
notebook and a pen.
And she says, "I like to take
time out of my computer."
And I love to take out of
my computer and my phones.
And I find that
when I disconnect
and I go into my journal and
I just write things down,
I start to connect more deeply
with myself, my emotional life.
Poems have come out of me.
This whole book came
out of reflection
and disconnecting from
the world to connect back
to me, and to something that
is much more bigger than who
we are and taking
time out of what
limits me to the part
of me that is unlimited.
And as I write, I
start to experience
that other creative
energy that we all have.
There's a chapter
in the book where
I call a lot about how to
tap into your creativity.
Because people sometimes
think, well, I'm not creative.
I'm not creative like
Mozart or Ernest Hemingway
or Picasso or Baryshnikov
or the great dancers,
and I can't sing like Adele.
Well, who can?
But we can all
sing in the shower.
I think Craig was there
and I said, do you dance?
And he said, "Well I dance
when I'm by myself, because I
don't like to be seen."
But it's like when we actually
stop ourselves and say, well,
creativity is
inherited in all of us.
And we can be creative.
If we remember when we
were little kids and you
were all creative, and that
creativity is really in us.
And each person, no
matter how busy we are,
we can all tap into
our own creativity.
It's how we do things.
How do we bring back the joy?
So how we wake up to the
joy is by giving ourselves
permission to get
out of our own stuff,
to get back to the
part of us that really
knows how to do our lives
in a calmer, happier, more
joyful way.
Taking time out every day
to be present with yourself,
because all of us get from
one thing to the other
and we got to do, got to do,
got to do, the deadlines,
and taking time
to teach ourselves
and retrain is like going to
the gym where you actually
start to train your muscles.
I mean, none of us go to the
gym once and build biceps.
It's sort of like
over and over again.
And that discipline,
that devotion,
and that discernment of what
is more important for us daily
is where, I think,
distinguishes a human being
from being a happier,
more fulfilled
human being, a human being
that includes themselves
in their lives, includes
their emotional life
and connects with themselves.
And then you become more
awake in who you are.
And the other habit is the habit
that really can take you down.
And each day is a choice.
How do we choose to
really be more present?
And how do you choose
to be more heartfelt?
Because ultimately
if you ask me,
Agapi, what is the secret
to happiness, I would say,
the secret to happiness is
keeping your heart open.
When our hearts are open--
how many of you have felt
when your heart is open,
like the gentleman who
said my little girl who
is two years old,
I mean, already you
feel the openness of his heart
as he talks about his daughter.
But imagine being like
that throughout the day
when he's with his
employees and when
he is with colleagues,
when he's with his friends,
and when he is with himself.
So how do we bridge the
separation between our heart
and ourselves?
And that's part of, when we
do a little guided meditation
afterwards, that's what
I would love to teach you
all is how do you get back
to being your bestest,
your bestest friend, your
kindest, most loving friend.
There is an
expression that I love
that says treat yourself as if
you were someone inexpressibly
dear to you.
Treat yourself as if you were
inexpressibly dear to you.
Treat yourself like you really,
really would treat someone
you really, really loved.
And then something
happens in the world
where our magic
starts to happen,
where we don't start to
disconnect from ourselves.
Because what really stresses us
is living a disconnected life.
And I'm sure all of you here
have felt this incredible surge
when we have a
connection with an idea,
with another human being,
with our colleagues,
with work, where you
feel suddenly connected.
Isn't that the most
wonderful feeling?
But it takes energy.
It takes consciousness.
It takes not being on autopilot.
Because when we are on
autopilot, we [INAUDIBLE]
automatic.
And life doesn't happen
we're on our automatic.
Life happens when we
actually wake ourselves up.
And it's really
waking up to our joy.
But how do you wake
up to your joy?
You also have to admit that
lesser feelings, the feelings
that we have that
we call negative,
so that when you're
feeling disconnected,
separate, upset, sad,
rejected, angry, people
who feel tremendous loss,
if we numb ourselves
to those feelings, we're going
to numb ourselves to our joy.
So in Greece, I don't know how
many of you have been there,
but I want to tell
you, in our vocabulary,
we don't have the word fine.
When you ask
somebody, how are you,
they say, I'm really,
really upset today.
Why are you upset?
Well because this person didn't
do what I asked them to do,
or because my boyfriend
came up too late at night.
And then you say he did?
You say yes, he did.
Well you say, well, let's
go kill the bastard.
Because you know,
Greek tragedies--
you've heard of
emotions are very big.
And we give ourselves
permission, Italians, Greeks,
Spaniards, you
know, Latin people,
they give themselves
more permission
to express their emotions.
And what happens when you
express your emotions?
You feel a sudden
aliveness, true?
So numbing ourselves to
our feelings that we judge
is also numbing
ourselves to our joy.
So how did you get into the
feelings that you judge?
You voice them.
You tell a friend.
Again, in Greece we
don't have therapists.
We have friends.
We talk to them forever.
Talk to your friends.
How many people have
had this release when
you have a safe place
with a friend to say,
this is what's going on.
I'm not happy here.
I'm not really happy in
the relationship when
you find that a
relationship isn't going
or you want more love or
you want more connection.
And part of what happens in
our culture is we isolate.
We hide from each other.
We feel a shame of
our own separation,
of our own loneliness,
of our own feelings
that are not elevated.
That's not good.
And I'll tell you
why that's not good,
because that's part of
what makes us human beings.
So when we face the true nature
of what we are experiencing
in the moment, we can
release ourselves from it
and go to another place
that is calm, that is happy,
and that is joyful.
Am I making sense to all of you?
Are you with me?
And where do we start with that?
We start by saying to
ourselves, I give you
permission to be all of you.
And it's like being
there for ourselves
no matter what's going on,
not in just the good times.
The most unhappiness
happens is because we
suffer from self-abandonment.
We abandon ourselves at the most
critical moments of our lives.
Everybody has gone through
a breakup in a relationship
where you suddenly feel,
he doesn't love me.
She doesn't love me.
There's a breakup.
And at that moment, not only
that person leaves, but then
we leave ourselves.
Because now we've
judged ourselves.
We've made ourselves
feel less than.
We feel love will
never happen again.
We do catastrophic thinking.
So part of this whole book is
I collected all this material
and all these stories from
everybody I learned out there.
And I realized that
we're all the same.
It's extraordinary.
We are all the same.
We all have the same issues.
It's just they look different.
Mine is the Greek
version, for example.
And men, women, we all want
more of the good things in life.
And we are scared to show
each other who we really are.
We're scared to show our hearts.
We're scared to reach
out, to connect.
Because why do you
think we're scared?
Because we feel we're
going to be rejected,
or because we feel people
are going to see us
and they're not going
to really like us.
And the human heart longs
to be known, to be seen,
to be shared, and to
live in gratitude.
Our human heart,
the physical heart,
beats 28.2 billion
times in a lifetime.
It beats.
It's the same heart
that in Bridget,
in Greece, in Nicole, in Agapi--
I don't know all your names--
in Bert, in Alexander,
it's the same heart.
It's the same beat.
But we as humans separate.
And we separate even
from people we love.
And we're afraid to reach
out and connect with them
and look in their eyes
and say, I love you.
And we are afraid to
really bring that love back
to ourselves, because we
feel it might go away.
So how do you open the channels?
Meditation, pausing is one
of the most amazing ways
to open the channels.
Kindness, caring, where
you start to realize,
it's like a thought and mindset.
You start to look at people
and you know they're not really
much different than me.
And that gives you
permission to open up.
And what is extraordinary
I found in my life
is that we are transparent.
Have you ever been in a
room and somebody walks in
and you know exactly
how they're feeling?
You know.
You know if they're upset.
You know if they're happy.
You know if they are
having a difficult moment.
How do we know?
Because our intelligence of
our heart is way bigger than we
give it credit.
Our intelligence of who we
are, if we gave ourselves
a chance, if we gave
ourselves permission,
is way bigger than the
intelligence of our brain.
Now getting to that, connecting
with that, is magic--
magic.
To miss that opportunity
in your lifetime
is such a shame, to
miss the opportunity
to connect with that
intelligence, the intuition,
your wisdom.
So I want to encourage
you all to start
connecting with that part
by actually writing down.
You can just take a journal
and say, the wisdom of my heart
is now speaking to me,
and open up the channels.
It's more like you're
giving it permission
and you're going
beyond the mind,
the chatter of the mind, the to
do list, into the to be list.
And then you start to
walk with your presence.
You know, we all have a soul and
a spirit, but we don't see it.
We see the physical body.
But you know all the
masters and all the mystics
talk about the soul.
To get to the soul, you
have to invite it in,
because the soul is sort of
hanging somewhere in there.
So I encourage you, as I said,
to live a day as a thank you,
to live a day, take a
day, and just invite
your soul in while you're
in your computers, when
you're doing your
deadlines, while you
are busy with everything.
Just have soul awareness,
spirit awareness.
It comes right from
your own breath,
because the breath
carries that spirit.
That's why all meditation
say, go back to the breath.
And that's where we
are going to do now
because we have a little time.
We're going to go back and
connect with our own breath.
So make yourself comfortable.
Open your hands a
little bit to receive.
Check your shoulders.
Relax your feet.
Relax your neck, and take
a deep breath and exhale.
And just take a deep breath.
And this time as you
take a deep breath,
imagine that this breath
is filling your whole body
all over your head
and down to your feet.
We're going to play
some very soft music.
And I want to ask you right
now, as you take a breath
and you exhale, exhale your
tensions, your worries.
Exhale anything
that's stopping you
from being fully
present in this moment.
And focus on your heart.
As you breathe in this time
and you focus on your heart,
soften your heart, and bring
in your awareness something
or someone you love.
And let your heart become
so tender and open.
This time as you breath in,
allow your breath to slow down,
to the count of four--
one, two, three, four.
And as you exhale,
four, three, two, one.
Start to think good thoughts.
Start to think
wonderful good thoughts
about yourself, all the
good things in your life.
And just say thank you.
Thank you for this moment.
Thank you for my breath.
Thank you for my health.
Thank you for this
work possibilities.
Thank you for my aliveness.
Thank you for my hands, my eyes
that see, my ears that hear.
And start to open up a space
inside of you that begins
to see with your inner eye.
Start to fall back
into yourself.
Beyond the idea of
who you are live
the being of who you truly are.
Let that be shown to you.
And as you receive
your next breath,
be in awe of your breath.
Where is my breath coming from?
How amazing it is
to be breathed.
It's the same breath
that breathes all of us.
And the best response is
to just say thank you.
And open your heart to yourself.
Allow that inner
light that we all
know and sense to
start to fill you up,
a light that comes
above your head
and connects you to your
heart, your emotional center,
fills your body, and your whole
energy with this inner light.
You might want to
take your right hand
and place it in your heart,
just to connect with yourself.
And you might want you
to take your left hand
and place it in your belly.
That's where the emotional
center is of all our emotions.
And start to feel how amazing
it is to take deep breaths,
slow breaths.
And as you exhale, imagine that
there are waves of calmness
that turn into waves of joy.
Start to be filled
with sunbeams inside,
like the sunbeam is
warming and illuminating
your consciousness.
And this time as you breathe
in, look into yourself
and tell yourself thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for all you do.
Thank you for all
you have overcome.
Thank you for your caring.
Slowing down the breath
is the greatest gift
to give to ourselves, because
then we become present,
and we give ourselves the signal
that there is plenty of time.
Time expands when we breathe
fully into our capacity.
Allow your thoughts to float by
like clouds in the sky, nothing
to do.
Just opening your heart
more deeply to yourself.
37.2 trillion cells
are breathing you,
making you happen.
The life force in
you is a miracle,
a miracle beyond ourselves.
And the only response is thank
you, and gratitude to the life
force, to the miracle
of life that is in you
and each person you meet.
Whenever you feel
disconnected, remember,
this is a place to
come right back to you,
knowing that you are more
than enough, that all is well
in your world.
And there is so many
possibilities to love more,
to have more joy, and to open
up to the gift of our lives.
Take a deep breath and
let this breath fall now,
and fill you to capacity
in your own breath,
sending a wave of energy to
your work, your coworkers,
your family, your loved
ones, sending this energy,
this presence, this calmness
to the world that needs it.
Like a canopy of
calmness, see everything
you touch from now on,
this moment, embraced
by this energy.
It is available to you 24/7.
Take it in.
You can go to a deeper
place inside of you.
And very gently smile
inside, like an inner smile,
as if you know something that
is the secret of your life.
Smile inside and smile outside.
And in this moment of peace
that you've created here
for yourself, place everything
that feels more difficult
or a struggle or you
would like more of,
place it in this energy of
creativity, of possibility,
of calmness, and of peace.
And in your creative
imagination,
start to see your day,
your days, and your life
the way you would like it to be.
Charge it.
Infuse it with good energy.
And start to see more
of, of the things
you would like in your life.
More of whatever you
would like, start
to see it and create
it, remembering
that you are a co-creator with
that life force in you, never
alone.
You can always return to that
place that is breathing you,
that is making your
life happen right now.
What a gift.
And very gently
whenever you're ready,
start to move your shoulders
a little bit and your neck.
And you can shake your
hands and your feet.
And whenever you're ready,
you can open your eyes.
And just take a deep breath
and extend your arms.
And with a sound like ah, as
if you are just coming back
to this life for a moment.
And one more breath
to the sound, ah.
And shake your shoulders.
And just smile.
Did that feel much calmer?
Did everybody feel--
everybody felt so--
looking so beautiful and calm.
You would think that we were
over at the Himalayas actually.
Everybody kind of was glowing.
So my friends, I just want to
invite you to give yourself
time, time to return to
yourself in your busy day
while you are in the
computer, while you
have all your deadlines,
just to remember,
never shut off your breath.
Give yourself this
conscious way of breathing.
That in itself can
change your life.
Start thinking of all the
thoughts of what you want
to create rather than
what you don't want.
Start thinking,
or write it down.
I want more of
that, more of that.
Is it material?
Is it physical?
Is it emotional?
Is it mental?
Is it spiritual?
It doesn't matter.
Make yourself into this
precious, amazing gift
of your life.
Don't take it for granted.
Remember my story on the plane.
In an instant in gratitude,
your life is transformed.
Look at people and acknowledge
them for who they are.
Appreciate them
over and over again.
Don't wait for special
occasions, birthdays,
and Christmas and
Easter and holidays.
Every day is your precious life.
As you read this book, the
way I wrote it for 52 chapters
is because you can
open it at any chapter.
You can take it and
say, I just need
a little help with
something, and just open it,
and there it is.
Suddenly you read "The
Gift of Intimacy."
Well, who would have thought
there's a gift in intimacy?
So you open it.
Keep it by your bedside.
Make it like your
companion where you just
want to get a little nugget,
a little inspiration.
I wrote this book out
of my life's experiences
of what I learned in
my life to overcome
my own challenges, my own
difficulties, my own stuckness,
my own ideas that I was failing.
I wrote it in a way to
show that there is always
an available new
path for all of us.
When I did the audio, I
put 32 guided meditations.
Why guided meditations?
Because like I did before with
all of you, when you're guided,
your mind can stay
a little more still,
till you learn to
be so quiet inside
and you listen to that
inner voice that's
always telling you, go there.
Don't go there.
Do this.
Don't do this.
Connect with so-and-so.
It gives you signals.
Like we talked
before, you always
are told of what's going on.
But we must listen.
We must listen to
the intelligence
of who we are, and not to just
give over to the little monkey
mind.
Are you with me?
Yes?
Write down every
night the things
you did that made you happy.
Your happiness matters.
You matter.
Write down the things
that bring you joy.
And find somebody to
be your joy buddy.
It's important to have
a joy buddy to remind
you to bring your joy and say,
what did you do for your joy
today?
And write down three things
that you're grateful for.
Gratitude-- joy triggers is a
shift to having a better life.
It's not going to happen.
Having a happier life is not
going to happen automatically.
So I want to leave you with
one of my favorite quotes
by Ian Thomas that says,
"Everyday, life will drag you
by the hand and say
this is important
and this is important,
and take care of this,
and this is what matters.
And it's up to you to
take your hand back,
put it in your heart, and
say, no, this is important."
So honor your heart.
It knows.
It speaks.
And it has things to tell you.
Listen to it.
It's a really powerful
intelligence we've been given.
37.2 trillion cells want
to connect with you.
You owe it to yourself to
connect back to you and then
with each other.
Thank you.
It has been an honor
and a privilege
to speak to this
amazing Google team.
I hear that Google employees are
the happiest employees around.
And I want to make
sure that is so.
So I wanted to contribute my
own wisdom and my own happiness
to bring you more
joy in your life.
Because if we miss the
joy, we've missed a lot.
Don't miss the joy that's
available to all of us.
Thank you so much from
the bottom of my heart.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]